you want to see how uh how everything's
going with rogan and his move to uh
spotify
yes oh i could do something for this
hold on wait a second i actually could
do something for this now that i have a
green screen hold on
hold on there we go i could do this
so now now now now we could talk rogan
all right so let's
let's do it here we go erogan experience
one thing i will say about spotify
layout though like as a fan you know i
want to tune into the pod sometimes
i find it hard did he call it the pod
yeah and why did he call it the pod
yeah and also why is he talking like
like like some
addiction recovery counselor from
celebrity rehab
he called it the pie the pod but why is
he
he's also speaking like this in a very
dr
drew way yeah you know like when i'm
listening to the pod bro
who is this guy i have no idea um
joe rogan experi fajim anwar i i love
rogan because rogan will literally have
the president of the united states on
and then the next day you're like
who is this guy who he'll have the
president of the united states on
and then some open micro from the comedy
store on the next day and it's like wow
talk about a
wild discrepancy in guests people are
saying people are saying that he's
pretty funny but i've never heard the
guy so who knows
tune into the pod sometimes i find it
hard to to watch on my tv
yeah so that sucks
is he eating i think he was eating you
can hear that pretty sure
well whenever rogan has a guest on that
isn't specifically
or guess that he doesn't necessarily
respect he'll just do whatever he wants
because he would not he would not be
munching in front of elon musk
no you know what i mean it's but it's
funny how forget about respecting the
guest right
you're still talking into the mic and
wrong no uh-huh
our guard bro and you're like okay man
like what about us joe
yeah they're gonna it's eventually gonna
be on all platforms
in terms yeah man it's crazy dude it's
just like it's like
we're just smoking tobacco in here in
texas
let's let's [ __ ] keep that angle
going let's keep lying to everybody and
saying that it's just tobacco
i thought is isn't we decriminalized in
austin i'm i
might i may be i think so i don't
i don't know no i know that texas
is a place you just don't want to [ __ ]
around and even if it is decriminalized
in austin
rogan's still very much like a can't
break the law man
like he doesn't want to ruin his image
of course like even if it's just like
um even if you just get like a summons
or something like i'm sure he doesn't
want that because you know because joe
rogan knows if he gets poppa
nickel bag of weed it's international
news it's going to be
you know right it's going to be [ __ ]
20 million hit pieces
in terms of like television based
platforms
well right now it's on chromecast and
it's going to be
on it's on google play and
they're working on roku and apple tv
they're working on a bunch of different
platforms that'll
eventually be but it's not as smooth as
it
probably should have been when it first
when we first transferred over in
december
but they just weren't ready for the
volume they had never had a show
first of all they they created video
because of the conversation we had about
this podcast yeah they wanted the
podcast
to be audio only and uh my manager was
like
think about the elon musk moment when
elon musk is smoking weed it's huge
getting his uh dick sucked in a cyber
truck that's
that's so embarrassing to say
it is it's kind of crazy to be in a
meeting and say but bro
imagine that moment where elon musk
smoked weed man
again i've been saying this a lot lately
i am glad
i'm glad the chinese are just gonna
[ __ ] dominate us
we deserve it they're just like i gotta
go make a more iphone
and we're just sitting here going bro
remember when hey yo
you remember when like elon musk went on
joe rogan dude
and he smoked weed bro that
is a viral moment that only happens with
video where elon's like it's legal right
i'm like yeah it's
totally huge i saw the painting yeah
they smoked the weed
remember that and then the tesla price
stock price crash dude remember that
it was awesome and they lost billions of
dollars in market cap in one day
remember i was at the airport and uh
i had sunglasses and a hat and i'm on my
way to vegas
and i'm like looking at this cnn monitor
and shows elon smoking weed on my
podcast
and i'm like oh no what a trip
i was like what have i done but those
moments those crazy viral moments
um they don't exist without video and my
manager said that to spotify
spotify is like you're right and then
they started working on the video
platform
and then you know there's been a lot of
weirdness like um a lot of uh
you know we're talking about like how
people
get a sense of who a person is without
actually communicating with them
without being there with them and you
could define someone
or you know have this like distorted
perception of who a person is without
actually
communicating with them that's one of
the things that happened with spotify
with like some of their staff where they
thought i was transphobic or thought i
was like
a bad person i saw one of their staff
say that i was a shock jack
shock jock well hold on a second you did
kind of
go hold on a second i did kind of start
out as a bit of a shot
he's he's not now i would say he's not
now no but rogan when he started doing
this stuff was absolutely
a shock jock there's not you got to
listen to his early rogue
there was a lot of n-word eff slurs yeah
you got to listen it was earlier [ __ ]
like we're talking like
when he was still doing it from his
house on like a 240p camera
red band yeah with the red band and
stuff he kind of was like remember the
[ __ ]
uh baby bird challenge on opie and
anthony that he was there and he was
like yeah this is radio this is [ __ ]
cool dude
you kind of were you're not anymore
maybe but you definitely started that
way
like that i'm not even remotely yeah
you're just a dude with a mic
yeah i always tell you yeah you're just
a dude with a mic and a 200 million
dollar contract in a salt bath in a 10
bedroom home
you're just like a regular gotcha i
don't care that rogan
has a lot of money good for him honestly
you're average joe but
but i'm really [ __ ] sick and tired of
pretending
like he's every man joe rogan because
he's not every man joe rogan you know
you don't get to [ __ ] you don't hang
out with elon musk
on a private jet and then come back and
go man i'm just a normal guy dude
polka sometimes i would almost respect
rogan moore if you would just
treat people like total [ __ ] if you were
to lean in lean into it
just be like i fly private you piece of
[ __ ] get out of my way
yeah well you know how i get on a plane
i walk across the tarmac
with security guards yeah
i know he's a comic and stuff so i see
you more as a comic than anything
so this guy's a comedian he's a comic
yeah
people saying he's funny that's what i
said i mean he might be one of those
guys that's very funny he might be very
dry but it's like i'm just
his energy right now is very you know
it's like i'm just kind of
i've just been kind of like down since
she left he's got that kind of energy to
him where i'm like jeez
you didn't intend on this becoming as
big as become
it's just organically grown and people
tune in because they want to tune in
you're not
you're not being force-fed down people's
throat they're like okay again
that's [ __ ] good for rogan i'm glad
that he
but to [ __ ] pretend that when rogan
was exclusively on youtube
that rogan wasn't being force-fed by
youtube's algorithm that's a [ __ ]
lie every one of our fans will tell you
that's true yeah
after all of our videos whether we were
talking to rogan right after our clips
after
our episodes how many emails did you get
how many members did i get messages
saying like
dude a rogan video again another broken
video auto plays after your video
another rogue interview will not auto
play one of our videos into one of our
videos
no we'll do it it always goes all right
you got a couple minutes revenge of the
system now
check out this guy this young hot
[ __ ] prospect joe rogan
this blue chipper choosing to listen to
you
yeah but when i've actually on purpose
never advertised for this show i've
never
asked people to watch it i've never gone
on television shows and
promoted it i've never taken out any
billboards or ads
spotify did some of that stuff when i
switched over to them but i never did
any of it
so i was thinking yeah but right now and
it's not it to be fair this is not him
but you've seen the rogan ads on youtube
right because i've been getting rogan
ads on youtube
and i mean not not i'm like i have ad
blocker here and on my phone
but but like you know by on my xbox for
example you can't really add block
and i see a lot of spotify rogan ads
coming up now now it's probably spotify
pain for them
but there are rogan ads are creeping
into places
odd when people hold you to the same
time browser yeah
i almost never see ads on that thing
anymore i only get ads
like what you said like if i'm watching
on my phone if i'm watching in the app i
get ads like that's where i've seen the
rogen ads but i don't see them on
brave which is great nbc or
these entities where you're just like a
guy with a mic
yeah you know what i mean but they don't
like it because it gets much more of an
audience than them
that's what freaks out so this is what
we do you go on rogan's show and you
just talk about him in his show
how cool he is yeah what a weird you'd
be surprised how many episodes
i'd have no problem in that situation
going is this what we're
just gonna talk about your show your
cool show
like it's like i used to have this guide
by weed from in south florida
he's a jewish fellow and he lived in
boca i know that's a
shock um but he was one of those guys
that every time he went to his house he
had to show you all of his stuff
it was one of those i know exactly and
it's so you know exactly what you're
talking about exhausting and this is
what that feels like it's like going to
somebody's house and
they're showing you all their stuff and
you're like
i had a long drive back to hollywood can
i just
get lead i gotta go to work tonight like
you know they'd be like yo check this
[ __ ] out bro
i got the surround sound dude that i had
to have four puerto ricans come put it
in
because it was like they to put it
drilling into the walls and [ __ ] you're
like that's
fascinating you do have the weed though
right
[Laughter]
these huge multinational corporations
that have
thousands of employees and they can't
even touch
the amount of reach that a guy with a
podcast has
yeah that's madness for them i've seen
clips of your like first well
again and that's what marketing's for no
you're right and these men the
multinational corporations can't touch a
guy with a podcast but
the guy with the podcast was being
lifted up and pushed into people's faces
by a
multinational corporation and this
wasn't
people going to joe rogan's they were
going to joe rogan.com to his
private video server and finding him i i
would i would venture to guess
that most people they're sure there's a
couple people that would say a little
differently but most people
that ever ran into rogan ran into rogan
because of the youtube algorithm i would
put money on it i
asked the chat room how did you guys run
into rogan did you guys run into rogan
because of youtube it just came up as a
recommended video because
i understand the organic but organic
kind of
but it was really more pushed and pushed
to you was like hey look at this guy
hey check this guy out hey look at rogan
look at rogan look at rogue and look at
rogan
you were you rogan was youtube's [ __ ]
baby
you know and i would say the only thing
the one thing that does make me happy
about rogan leaving youtube
for spotify was [ __ ] youtube a little
bit which kind of makes me happy
that he kind of just said [ __ ] you guys
i'm taking my ball and i'm [ __ ] out
of here
good for him but it was because of
youtube
i would say most of rogan's listeners
weren't actively searched out
no one was actively searching out for
joe rogan
madness for them i've seen clips of your
like first episode or whatever or
pictures it's like absurd it's absurd
you know it's been an organic thing
you can see yeah you can see how it
grows but
it's also a lesson to all these other
comics too like what's the difference
well the difference i
grind i just keep going i i can't
mike mike i can't mike mike i give up
i'm tapping on mike i can't
mike i can't rise and grind bro
i can't i i can't i can't i can't
i can't did he really say he grinds
bro grinds hard oh my god oh my god
oh my god yeah the same thing with you
that got you good at comedy what got you
good at comedy stage time
what gets you good at podcast podcast
time you know what no one's doing it
well it's deep
even just doing my podcast because
especially during the past what's it
called dance time for
man or dance hour dance hour it's
hilarious that he came on this show and
sucked rogan's dick
and rogan had to go what's the name of
your podcast by the way rogan
i think he is trying to help him out
because this guy's just babbling and he
is trying to get like he is probably
saying
this kid's coming on here like at least
give get one [ __ ] plug-in
no no but he doesn't know the name of
his podcast i know he genuinely doesn't
of course but why would he
because if you're grinding on a podcast
like when we have a guest on we'll have
a notepad open with like their
information on it so we can at least
know who we're talking to right if
you're grinding well
yeah but i mean uh
[ __ ] it's yeah if you have like
certain guests on but if you're joe
rogan and you've got
whatever nasim bogdanovich or whatever
the [ __ ] this guy's name is
are you really gonna watch this guy's
podcast
yeah no no yeah i get that he's not i'm
so rogan's too busy listening to five
finger death punch at the gym
rolling around on the rolling around on
the ground with eddie bravo
you're wrong it's avenged sevenfold and
you're making a mockery out of the music
you listen to
oh you [ __ ] making a mockery out of
music
yeah that's that's all he does now is
listen to five finger death punch and
roll around on the ground with eddie
bravo and that's fine
feminine just uh when the pandemic hit
you lean i do have the old joe rogan
background i need for the green screen i
need the new joe rogan toaster
background
we could do the toaster background we
could definitely do the toaster
background
[ __ ] bro think about like
podcasting ah here we go with this
conversation again
so deep yo man it's like think about
think about like stand-up or like
podcasting i'd rather not you i'd rather
not think
about either of those things
it's like when you're like like me like
when i get up in the morning like
anybody could do this man it's
wild like what i do is i get in my one
of my several salt tanks that i have in
my home
like all you need is three spare bad
bathrooms you don't have those
and you just meditate a little bit and
you know what i do it's like
i grind and i do dmt and then you know i
don't
and you know i i work less than i ever
have in my life because i don't go to
ufc
stuff anymore either and i won't do the
voiceover work anymore either
and spotify bro get this they let me
pre-record my shows
so i could put like 30 in a can in a
week yeah and that just goes and then i
just soaked
myself in some salt water tank it's
[ __ ] crazy dude
it's nuts yeah it's nuts it really does
just he's it's so funny how they're
paying him all his money and he's
putting in less
effort than ever and he's like yeah cool
man this is great i love this
but like the whole thing about talking
about podcasting or comedy
or acting like show business people
suck nowadays i was watching this clip
the other day
of uh old like old letterman when he was
on the late night show
and he had steve allen came on his show
and you know steve allen was a legend
everybody thought steve allen was like a
huge legend at the time
and of course you know letterman's you
know sucking his dick a little bit but
he was like you know you're the guy that
you know invented this format he's like
you know johnny carson
obviously became the big dog but like
you invented the tv variety show and the
radio variety show
and like hearing steve allen have like
humility and be humble
it's like if steve allen can be humble
you guys because he goes oh you invented
all this and he goes
i didn't invent it i just did it first
he's like somebody was gonna come along
and do this
what you know he's like i wasn't some
genius it was just that time was coming
where radio and tv and theater were
merging
and i s i saw variety shows and i was
like
this would work on tvs like but trust me
he's like i'm not some visionary he's
like
because within a couple of years
somebody else was going to be watching
the show and go
this belongs on tv he's like i just
rushed to do it first
right and it's like but these guys
really sit around and think about
like how you know because that guy
created an entire genre steve allen
but these guys that do podcasts just
hang out in their house and bang out a
quick hour and then they go
you know it's like the thing about man
when you reach so many people
it's like you know it's really profound
the relationship you have with your fans
it's like shut up dude
stop it you're not you're not [ __ ]
shaping the world dude stop
have a little [ __ ] humility look man
we're microscopic we're [ __ ]
whatever we do a stupid podcast for like
38
000 people that subscribe on youtube and
whatever how many people
listen to us and that's fine i've never
sat here and thought
man i'm going to change the world man
like i'm really like i'm just like i'm
just going to come on and phone my
friend like that's pretty much it that's
my [ __ ] mindset when it comes to this
it should be probably everybody else's
like
a lot of these guys when they get big
and not all of them so to be fair but
they start taking themselves way too
serious
like way too seriously they really start
thinking like that
they're changing the planet and i think
that
look even with all this that we're
saying
i don't hate joe rogan okay i'll say
that right
i don't hate your rights fun to laugh at
he's fun joe rogan
in terms of the things that we cover and
the dummies that we cover and the idiots
that we cover
joe rogan is pretty harmless for the
most part
yeah but he there's some things about
rogan that are very
very silly yes um
for example rogan trying to be every man
when he's clearly not
and look i'm not [ __ ] on somebody's
success but like mike said
i would rather you [ __ ] just be
honest about looking like
there was a real there was a real moment
when rogan had rob lowe on
and they were talking about like the
industry and this and that to where
rob lowe had this real moment where he
goes dude nobody understands what he did
he goes nobody understands what we're
talking about like
we're talking about hollywood and all
these stuff like most people listening
don't even
get this and rugby was like yeah i guess
you're right like so every once in a
while you have a light bulb go off but
this whole like understanding what it's
like to be every dude look
i never when i watch carson the carson's
a great example when i was a kid and i
watched carson
i never thought that carson was trying
to be
every man carson was doing his show
carson did his jokes
but carson was a [ __ ] rich dude and
he was well off
i carson was just giving you a glimpse
of show business every right
that was his job right his job was to
get big stars to come in and let you
get a little gander at them and talk
about hollywood stuff so that
yeah you're right it's different when he
did it but when these podcasts are doing
it and by the way
even carson though carson wouldn't sit
around and talk about
the craft and how much it meant and how
powerful what they were doing was
that's my problem with the podcasters
and the comedians everybody's like man
it's like
you know when you have influence like
this and you're speaking truth to power
man
it's like stop it you just hang out and
do your [ __ ] jokes get out of there i
don't know why
that's why i like that's why we get
along with ryan long i like ryan long
because he doesn't have
he doesn't have some [ __ ]
philosophical [ __ ] reason for
comedies
or any male clothes or any milk
or good manners yeah the point is it's
that he says like
i just want to be funny like put me out
i want to say funny [ __ ] you know what
he does if you say funny [ __ ] i want to
laugh at you funny
i don't want to sit here and [ __ ]
dissect it like a frog in biology class
and go well what made that joke tick
it's like i just let's be funny man
you know what he does have though a drug
problem
so that's cool no it's like it's like
the lawyer from sleepers
uh i i also have a
a slight in addition to the drinking
problem a slight
drug problem